PROFESSOR: We had begun to
discuss, really what is,
although you would not gather
it from last time, a fairly
straightforward matter.
Set up our usual Cartesian
coordinate system.
And then look at the surface of
the solid, and applied to
this solid a force per unit
area, which we'll represent by
a vector k.
And then put on some
labels here.
Let this be O. Let this be A,
let this be B, and this be
point C. Then we
proceeded to--
I will say, attempt to--
set up a balance of forces
between the external force per
unit area and the internal
forces per unit area, which
have to push back on the
external force if the solid is
to remain motionless.
The thing that I did not carry
through is that there are two
directions involved.
One is the direction to the
normal, to the particular
surface that we're looking at.
We'll call that N. And there is
the direction that k, the
vector k, makes with respect to
the three reference x axes,
x1, x2, x3.
Let's take k and immediately
split it up into the three
components, k1, k2, k3, because
throughout, we're
going to be dealing with the
balance of those three forces
per unit area in the directions
of x1, x2, and x3.
We want to take this surface
area and resolve it into three
separate areas that are
normal to x1, x2, x3.
And what I did at the end of
last hour was to look at k and
try to express these internal
areas in terms of the
direction cosines of k.
Forget that.
We've split up k into its three
components, and I didn't
draw in the direction
of the normal to the
surface N last time.
So I kept saying, direction
cosines of k, and people in
the audience said,
no, no, no, no.
And I said, yeah, because you
see, that's the ratio
of these two areas.
And everybody said, no, that's
wrong, and I said, ha.
And that's where we ended
my most inglorious hour.
And they've got this
all down on tape.
My reputation's going
to be ruined.
So, anyway, let's now
do it properly.
And what I will say is that in
the x1 direction, we have to
have internal forces that push
back, and we have to balance
those forces in all
three directions.
So I'll say is that in the x1
direction, and this as you saw
last time, gets very cumbersome
because we have to
deal with all these clumsy
areas, that the force per unit
area on ABC has to be balanced
for each of the three
components of k by internal
forces acting
along x1, x2, and x3.
So we can say is that the first
in the x1 direction, the
component of k that acts on
the surface ABC in the x1
direction has to be balanced
by internal forces.
And let's look first at
the x1 direction.
So there are three internal
surfaces.
They are the area BOC.
That is this back surface here,
and the normal to that
surface is x1.
So let me define some forces
per unit area that are
internal, and I'll use the
term sigma for that.
And I will use a first subscript
that gives the
direction in which that force
per unit area acts, and I'll
use a second subscript that
indicates the normal to the
internal surface.
So area BOC obviously, as we
observed a moment ago, has x1
as its normal.
But there are three
internal surfaces.
There will also be an internal
area, AOC, on which a force
per unit area acts in
the x1 direction.
So I'll call this one
by analogy to what I
did a moment ago.
I'll call this sigma 1, because
it acts in the x1
direction, and it acts on the
surface AOC, which has x2 as
its normal.
Then finally, there will be a
third force per unit area,
sigma 1 3, acting in the x1
direction, on a surface whose
normal is perpendicular
to-- along x3.
The surface is perpendicular
to x3.
And that's area AOB.
OK, so this is just a simple
balance of forces, external
and internal balancing forces,
which act in the x1 direction.
Then we'll write a similar thing
for the x2 direction.
And we'll say that the x2
component of force per unit
area external to the volume
element acting on area ABC is
going to be balanced by, again,
forces now acting in
the x2 direction.
So first, there will be a
component of 4 sigma 2 acting
on the area that's normal to x1,
and that's the same area
BOC, plus another force per
unit area acting in the x2
direction on the surface, whose
normal is a long x2.
And that is, once
more, area AOC.
And that would be a force per
unit area that I'll define,
because it's my ball game
and I own the ball.
So again, that would be sigma 2
2, and then finally a sigma
2 3 times the area whose
normal is x3.
And I think I need not write
the third term that follows
automatically from what
I've written so far.
So now comes the geometry part,
where I'm going to get
rid of these messy areas, and
I'm going to divide through by
the external area on the
surface of the solid.
I will then write accordingly
that k1 is equal to sigma 11
times the ratio of area BOC
divided by area ABC plus sigma
12 times area AOC divided
by area AOB--
ABC, excuse me.
Then finally sigma 1 3 times
area AOB divided by area ABC.
So now I'll introduce a little
bit of geometry that caused
such difficulties last time.
If I have an area and project
it onto another area that
makes an angle C with respect
to the first, this area A
prime is equal to the area A
times the cosine of Phi and
you could define that Phi in a
different way, namely take the
normal to one of the two areas
and let M prime be the other
normal, so C then is exactly
the same thing as the angle
between the normals to
these two surfaces.
So let's now look at what the
ratio of these two areas that
we have is.
What we're dealing with here is
an angle between the normal
to the surface, not k, but the
normal to the surface, and
either x1, x2, or x3.
So the ratio of--
let's look at one of these
specific terms.
The ratio of area BOC through
the ratio of the area ABC
should be the cosine of the
angle between the normal to
the surface and the normal
to area BOC.
Well, the normal to area BOC is
x1, so that first ratio of
areas is just going to be the
cosine of this angle.
And that cosine is just the
direction cosine of N1 along
the x1 of M along the
x1 direction.
So this is just the direction
cosine between N, the normal
to the surface, and x1.
And let me say then that, by
definition, I'll let the
direction to the normal be its
three direction cosines, L 1
plus L 2, plus J plus
L3 times k.
These are the direction cosines
of the normal to the
surface, and not k.
So this then simply comes down
to sigma 11 times L1, the
ratio of the area AOC to ABC
is going to be the angle
between N and x2.
And that's the angle whose
direction cosine is L2.
And similarly, the ratio of
these two areas will be cosine
minus 1 of L3.
So this cumbersome construction
with ratios of
areas just reduces to sigma 11
L1 plus sigma 12 times L2 plus
sigma 13 times L3.
And the other two equations will
follow a similar form.
K2 will be sigma 21 times L1
plus sigma 22 times L2 plus
sigma 23 times L3.
Or in general, case of I will be
given by sigma I J times L
to J. Easy.
Nice and compact.
Nice and simple.
What can we say about this?
K is a vector which has
components k1, k2, and k3.
The direction cosines can be,
as we said a moment ago, can
be regarded as the components
of a unit vector pointing
along the normal
to the surface.
So k is a vector.
These three direction cosines
are the direction cosine to a
unit vector normal
to the surface.
If we were to be so foolish to
try to change the coordinate
system., having just gotten it
right for the first time in
one coordinate system, we know
exactly how the two vectors
will change because
we have a law for
transformation of a vector.
If we were to change the
coordinate system, the
components of k would wink on
end of and take new values and
we know exactly how the
components of a vector will
change as we change
coordinate system.
OK, if this transforms like a
vector and this transforms
like the vector, then the 3 by
3 array of coefficients which
relate those to quantities
must be a tensor.
So we've proven rigorously that
sigma IJ is a tensor, in
particular, it's a second
rank tensor.
And were we to change coordinate
system, we know
from what we've done in the
past, exactly how the numbers
that make up this 3 by 3
array will transform.
These quantities, sigma IJ,
are something that you've
probably encountered, introduced
to be sure,
probably in a little
different way.
These are the elements of
stress, and sigma IJ is the
stress tensor.
We can immediately, on physical
grounds, established
that sigma IJ must be
a symmetric tensor.
So let's set up two axes, x1,
and x2, and x3 obviously is
normal to the board.
And let us look at some
off-diagonal terms like sigma
12 and sigma 21.
Sigma 1 2 would be a force
acting on the x1 direction on
a surface whose normal is x2.
So this is going to be a sheer
stress and that, to prevent
any translation of the volume
element, must be balanced by a
sigma 12 on the other
face that acts in
the opposite direction.
We're going to need a convention
for defining sign,
S-I-G-N, of what constitutes a
positive element of stress and
a negative element of stress.
And I'll define a plus sigma
IJ as a force per unit area
acting in the plus xi direction
on a surface whose
normal is plus xj.
So if this is a force per unit
area acting on this surface,
and it acts in the direction
of x1 on a surface whose
normal is x2, what I've shown
here is a positive sigma 12.
A sheer force going in the
opposite direction would be a
negative sigma 12.
A positive sigma 11 would be
a stress that's tensile, a
negative sigma 11 would be a
stress that's compressive.
So here's a sigma 12, a sigma
12 on the opposite face.
If we went away and turned our
back, this volume element
would start accelerating,
getting an angular
acceleration, would start
furiously spinning about the
x3 axis like a top.
So something, if this volume
element is, by definition, an
equilibrium, something has
to balance this couple.
And if it's to stay put, we must
have a sheer force like
this and a sheer force
like this.
And that's the only thing
available from the nine
elements of stress that will
give a net torque on the
volume element.
So what are these?
This is a stress that
acts on the surface
whose normal is x2--
whose normal as x1 in
the x2 direction.
So this is sigma 21.
It acts in x2 direction,
and its normal is x1.
An x, and then [? plus ?]
x2 direction on [? I ?]
surface, which has a normal
that is along x1.
So the only way we can avoid an
angular acceleration is to
say that sigma 12 has to be
identical to sigma 21 if
there's no rotation about x3.
And looking at the couple's that
act about x2, and x3, we
could say in general that sigma
IJ is going to have to
be equal to sigma JI for a
volume element in equilibrium.
So stress then is equilibrium
is in place, has to be a
symmetric tensor.
It is, however, a plain old
second-rank tensor like all of
the other second-rank tensors
that we've spent the last
month talking about.
And I think I tried to swindle
you on this one before.
If this is a second-rank tensor,
the stress tensor must
be symmetric and diagonal
for a cubic crystal.
In other words, the stress
tensor sigma IJ must have the
form sigma 0 0, 0 sigma 0, 0 0
sigma because we've shown that
that is what is required of a
tensor if the crystal has
cubic symmetry.
So surprisingly, you cannot
subject a single crystal with
cubic material to
sheer stress.
Any quarrel with that?
Should we move on?
We better not, but somebody
better raise an objection.
That's not true, obviously.
I can take a cubic crystal and
shear the stuffings out of it.
So what's going on here?
AUDIENCE: The tensor property
that you are applying to
[INAUDIBLE]
property of the [? crystal. ?]
But if it is an outside force,
it doesn't [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: This is one
of your good days.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
society [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That makes it an
especially good day because
you're paying attention to
what I said for a change.
The distinction here, and I did
make it last time-- it was
one of the things that
I did correctly--
that there are really two kinds
of things that have to
be described by second-rank
tensors.
There are the things that we
have been spending most of our
time on, and these are property
tensors and--
I mentioned last time, too, so
I know I said this before--
Nye calls them field tensors.
I'm sorry.
Nye calls them property
tensors, also.
And these are something that
depends on the structure and
bonding and other
characteristics of the material.
The stress is something that we
we're taking and imposing
on an innocent, unsuspecting
crystal, and that is
something we do.
And we can, by design, twist it,
shear it, stretch it, as
hard as we like, provided
we don't break it.
And so this is something that
is externally imposed on the
crystal, and this is something
that's called a field tensor.
We mentioned last time
the meaning of field.
The field is a volume of space
and a field tensor is a space
in which a value of the tensor
is defined as every point, x1,
x2, x3, in the space.
Just as an electric field is a
vector field and you define
the electric field we as a
function of every point x1,
x2, x3, in the space.
So there's no reason whatsoever
that there need be
restrictions on the tensor
that we apply.
And when we can cross out that
interesting, but incorrect,
supposition.
But they can be a lot of
different forms, special
forms, of stress tensors which
have special forms simply
because of the nature
of what we do.
And these have restrictions and
equalities that have no
counterpart in property
tensors.
For example, we can have the
cancer sigma 00000000, which
is something we could never
have identically so for a
property tensor.
And what does this represent?
This is a tensor for which sigma
IJ is 0, unless I equals
J equals 1.
So this is the only thing that's
going on, is a force
per unit area along
the x1 direction.
So this is a uniaxial stress.
And that is a stress field
which we could apply on a
piece of material very easily.
Just screw a hook into the
material and hang a weight on
the hook and you've got
uniaxial stress.
We can also have something
that's a little harder to
visualize, a biaxial stress.
And this would be a stress that
had elements sigma 11,
register 0--
at least when we refer
to principal axes--
0 sigma 2 2 0 0 0 0.
When it's in diagonal
form, two of the
diagonal terms are 0.
That doesn't seem to make sense
because, if this is a
force per unit area along x1,
and this is a force per unit
area along x2, can't we add up
those vectors and say that
that's a uniaxial stress?
Depends on your coordinate
system.
If you want an example of a
biaxial stress, imagine some
firemen underneath a burning
building, and they're holding
out a blanket for somebody
to jump into.
You have one pair of firemen
pulling in this direction to
keep the blanket taut, and
another pair of firemen are
not quite so vigorous, and
they're pulling in an
orthogonal direction.
And those two forces, sigma 11
and sigma 22, create a biaxial
stress event material.
You could change the form of
the tensor by rotating the
coordinate system, but
this is one example
of a biaxial stress.
The final general form, a
triaxial stress, obviously by
extension, is going to be where
of all three diagonals,
sigma 11, sigma 22, and sigma
33, are non-zero when you put
the tensor in diagonal form.
This would be a general
triaxial stress.
And an example of that would
be when the jumping person
lands on the blanket, there's
going to be a force that his
or her mass exerts on the
blanket, and that would be a
third sigma 3 3.
So that would be a
triaxial stress.
Let me give you a couple of
special cases of specialized
stress tensors.
And suppose I had a triaxial
stress, but all the diagonal
terms were equal.
That's something that I tried
a moment ago to hoodwink you
into believing was required by
a cubic crystal, but suppose
that was the form of
the stress tensor.
What would that represent?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That is something
that's going to be--
yeah, very good.
That's not a pressure.
It's a dilation.
But if I make it into a more
familiar form, put it here,
minus P, minus P, minus P. It's
a force prevented area.
That's where the stress is.
If it's a hydrostatic pressure,
it's squeezing the
volume element so it has to be,
by our definition, acting
in a negative x1 direction
on a surface whose
normal is plus x1.
So minus P, minus P,
minus P, represents
a hydrostatic pressure.
And now, unless you've seen it
before, or you're reading the
notes instead of listening to
me, let me give you a really
strange-looking one.
What is this stress tensor?
Where sigma 22 is opposite
in sign but equal in
magnitude to sigma 11.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Good.
The way to see that
geometrically is the following.
What we're doing is, we're
pushing with a force per unit
area in this direction.
That would be sigma 11, and
then we squeeze in the
orthogonal direction.
And that is a sigma 22,
which is negative.
If we rotate the solid by 90
degrees, then we've got this,
plus this, acting on this face,
same forces per unit
area as we have here.
And that is a net force per
unit area like this.
On the opposite surface, we've
got this force per unit area
and this force per unit
area, component
going in this direction.
And that is going to be a force
that goes like this.
That's going to be a force per
unit area like this, and
similarly, this combined with
this is going to be a force
acting in the reverse
direction.
That would be, again, this with
this, and this would be
this with that.
So clearly, that is a body
that's being subjected to pure
sheer, and if we rotated the
axes x1 and x2 by 45 degrees
to an x1 prime and x2 prime
like this, and then
transformed the tensor, it
would take the form 0
sigma sigma 0 0.
And then, what do we want now?
This would be the only
thing we get.
Except I should be careful to
put a sigma prime on this
because, when we change axes,
these sigmas will not be of
the same magnitude as
the original ones.
There's going to be a square
root of 2 coming from cosine
of 45 degrees in there.
But, anyway, just rotating the
axes 45 degrees of as I've
indicated schematically here
with vector sums is going to
give me two off diagonal terms
equal in magnitude that would
correspond to sigma
12 and sigma 21.
So those are some special forms
of a stress tensor when
you place it in a diagonalized
form.
But let's conclude this part of
our discussion by observing
that everything that we've said
about second-rank tensors
holds for the stress tensor.
For example, you can always
select new axes that put the
tensor in diagonal form.
So that's one general
property.
You can define a stress quadric,
and we'll do that
with the equation sigma
ij xi xj equals 1.
Why not?
It's a second-ranked tensor.
We can take the elements and
construct a surface from it.
This quadric will have the
properties of any other
quadric for a second-rank
tensor.
In particular, if we construct
the quadric, it's now for sure
going to be able to be either
an ellipsoid, an hyperboloid
of one or two sheets, or in this
case, even an imaginary
ellipsoid for a stress that's
everywhere compressive.
The quadric could have
its diagonal
elements all negative.
The radius of the stress
quadric in a particular
direction is going to be the 1
over the square root of the
property in that direction.
What does that mean, stress
in a given direction?
Well, let's again remember
how we have
defined the stress tensor.
A force per unit area has three
components, k1, k2, k3,
and they're equal to
sigma ij times lj.
So the value of the property in
this direction is going to
be the value of the property
in the direction defined by
[? elsa ?] j and the values of
[? elsa ?] j are components of
the unit vector that point
in that direction.
So if this is the direction of
k, [? off ?] like this, the
value of this quadric in this
direction is going to be the
value of the part of k that's
parallel to the radius vector
over the magnitude of
the radius vector.
But the [? radius ?] vector is
a unit vector, so it's simply
going to be equal
to k parallel.
And if k parallel is the part
of the vector that is along
the surface normal, that is
going to be the component of k
which is purely tensile.
This is a force per unit area,
has parts that are, components
that are normal to the
surface normal.
Those are shear components.
The component that's directly
along the normal to the
surface is going to be a purely
tensile component.
And, therefore, the radius
of the quadric in a given
direction gives us the tensile
component of the force density
vector k that is transmitted
across the face--
so let's not say face,
but interface--
whose normal is in the
direction of R.
So this is the radius vector.
That's the direction of the
normal to a surface and 1 over
the radius of--
The radius of the quadric in
that direction is going to be
1 over the square root of the
tensile component of stress
that's transmitted across an
interface in this direction.
How are we doing on time?
Any questions at this point?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain how
you know that's [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Remember what our
radius normal property said.
If we have a tensor like good
conductivity, where a current
density is related to an
applied electric field,
[? essa ?] j and we've--
unfortunately, that's
segment 2.
This is the conductivity
tensor.
What we said is that, if we
take the components of the
tensor, sigma ij, and construct
the surface sigma ij
xij equals unity, that will be
some sort of quadratic form
that has the property that the
radius in any given direction
is 1 over the square root of
the value of the property,
sigma conductivity
in this case.
Bad case.
I shouldn't have picked
things where the
sigma is also involved.
And the value of the property
in the given direction is
going to be the parallel
component of what happens over
the magnitude of what you do.
So in the case of electrical
conductivity, if we apply a
field in this direction, the
value of the property is going
to be that part of the current
flow, which is parallel to the
electric field, divided
by the magnitude of
the electric field.
So that is a relation that you
know by heart and have come to
not only know, but to love.
So what are we saying here?
For the stress tensor, we can
take the elements of the
stress tensor and construct
a quadric.
And the thing that's related
here is a force per unit area
that we're applying to the
surface of the crystal, and
that's transmitted through the
volume of the crystal by the
relation that we have defined
as the stress tensor.
So, unfortunately,
again, sigma Ij.
And now what is involved are the
direction cosines of the
normal to the surface.
So what is the applied vector?
The applied vector is a unit
vector, and this is the normal
to the surface.
And the surface in question
would be a surface like this.
The thing that results is
a force per unit area k.
So what we're doing is taking
k, the value of
sigma, in that direction.
A scalar quantity will be the
part of k that's parallel to
the normal vector,
divided by the
magnitude of the unit vector.
And that's, a magnitude
of n is 1, so
that's just k parallel.
So this is the surface.
This is its normal.
And what the radius of the
quadric is going to give us is
that part of the force density,
which is the force
density vector resolved onto
the normal vector.
And this is a tensile.
This is the part of the
tensile stress that's
transmitted.
This is the total stress
that has a sheer part
and a tensile part.
The radius of the quadric is
going to give you the part
that's transmitted across the
surface in this orientation.
That is purely a
tensile force.
That make sense?
I should have done it
without sigmas being
present in both tensors.
So everything you want to know
about stress that's applied to
a solid is contained in a
second-rank tensor that is
symmetric and obeys all of the
characteristics that we
derived earlier for property
tensors, even though this is a
field tensor, and not
a property tensor.
Let us then turn to the next
thing that I want to discuss,
again something you've
heard before.
But we'll do it within the
context of the tensor algebra
that we've developed before.
And this is the concept
of strength.
And let me introduce
the subject by a
one-dimensional analog.
Suppose we have a very thin
elastic band fastened to some
immovable surface, and this
will be the direction x.
And then we pull on it.
And here again, we have to be
complete and note that there
are several different
kinds of behavior.
One type of behavior is a case
where the elastic band
stretches, and if there's some
point P on the initial state
that point P will move to
a point P prime that is
displaced from the original
location by a vector U.
There's another point Q part
way along the elastic band.
If the thing that we have
fastened to the elastic band
slipped, and there's no
deformation at all, Q would be
displaced by the same amount U
if there was just translation
of the elastic because it wasn't
fastened down solidly.
But if it's stretching here
between this point and this
point, it's going to stretch
up here, too.
And, in general, it will move
over to some point Q prime,
and this displacement vector is
going to be the original U
plus delta U. And what we care
about in defining strength is
not the absolute coordinates,
but the interval
between these points.
This separation is U, and this
separation is U plus delta U.
Now this is a common, but
not a necessarily
unique, sort of behavior.
This is something where the
displacement does not change
along the length of
the elastic bands.
This is something that's
called homogeneous
deformation.
And this is characterized by a
displacement view that varies
linearly with position along
the elastic band.
Does something like this.
It's possible, in a [? grade ?]
of material, if
you'd like a real example,
that U, as a function of
distance along this
one-dimensional object, does
something like this.
Why not?
That's what might happen
for example in--
that's almost an oxymoron, a
one-dimensional elastic band
whose cross-sectional area
changes with distance in that
one dimension.
So this is homogeneous
deformation, as opposed to
inhomogeneous deformation.
There's another type of
behavior, and this is apparent
if you place a thin piece of
metal or plastic, let's say,
between the pair of grips in the
Instron machine, and after
deformation, it does something
like this.
There's an inhomogeneous
deformation, which is to
referred to colloquially
as necking.
A very good example of that is
what happens when you grab
hold of some cheap plastic
shrink wrap that has been
shrunk around a package that
has been mailed to you.
And you want to get it
off, so you grab it.
And it doesn't deform
elastically.
What happens is that it necks
in places where there's a
stress concentration.
And you get something
exactly like this.
And if we were to indicate that
sort of behavior, U as a
function of position would be
one U, and then it would
increase very rapidly.
The [? UDX ?]
would be very much larger than
the places which had uniform
elastic deformation, so it would
be a nonlinear behavior
of this sort.
And that would be necking.
If you've never noticed that
sort of behavior before, I
give you an assignment tonight
of going home and getting a
piece of Saran wrap from your
kitchen drawer and grabbing
hold of it and pulling it.
And it deforms non-uniformly in
a fashion that's indicative
of necking.
OK, it's just about five of.
Why don't I stop there.
And what I would like to do next
is to cast this relation,
which is a one-dimensional
stream, into a
three-dimensional situation.
And we'll look at some of the
properties of the description
of a body that's been deformed
in three dimensions.